bonsoir monsieur zulawski alors tout le
monde connaît angeles qui évidemment
l'important c'est d'aimer possession la
femme publique l'amour brac mes nuits
sont plus belles que vos jours chamanga
la fidélité vous êtes également
essayiste et écrivain et vous publiez
votre 20e livre ça je sais pas si les
gens ne savent votre 20e bouquin tu le
savais toi bien sûr qu évidemment chez
stock auparavant à la 20e en polonais
attendait puisque 4e en france est
maintenant quatrième livre en france et
20e livre en pologne l'infidélité publié
par agnès parayre jeune éditrice
française qui était à limoux convaincre
en pologne de faire traduire ce livre
laurie paris s'est réfugié dans une dans
une forêt près de varsovie que vous
vivez retranché comme ça dans un chalet
iman 600 m² 909 sans erreur et ran et
qu'est ce vous faites w de la vodka vous
taper à la machine toute la journée oui
je vois de la vodka et un chocolat est
un
championnat
non ça fait trois ans que je suis un
tout petit peu en dehors des choses il
le fallait j'ai eu quelques
bouleversements
difficile dans la vie donc c'est pas la
peine de parler et donc je me suis
retrouvé dans une maison que j'avais
acheté avant et qui est une maison
d'antan dans un énorme parc national qui
donne sur une ferait donc on construira
jamais rien en face de moi il ya des
loups et à dessert il ya des tas
d'animaux y avait des sangliers c'est ce
que voulait je suis très heureux là
dedans ouais mais c'était un peu une
grande solitude et je remercie 1 et ce
par air ou alors le livre était
autobiographique genre on peut le dire
c'est pas non non non c'est un autre
roman camps de roms en valeur dans
autrement il ya auto hier gouvernement
vers la fin c'est l'histoire d'un
philosophe qui soupçonne sa femme
actrice de le tromper
[Musique]
frederik je les lui oui j'ai lu pas ce
que je fait que les étrangers pour voici
venir une page dans les dans deux
semaines sur le livre est très
franchement je ne suis pas un fanatique
du cinéma très hystérique 2 ou le ski
mais non mais j'ai beaucoup mais c'est
l'année ce qui n'est pas injurieux c'est
un cinéma paroxystique de scènes assez
tendu un les acteurs bon mais ça n'a
rien à voir ce livre là est au contraire
extrêmement doux extrêmement calme même
si à la fin il ya un crescendo violent
c'est un livre de rencontre et il ya
donc effectivement une double narration
parce qu'il ya deux philosophes dont
l'un a été quittée quand même par une
actrice un les deux qui j'ai un vieux
jamais agi à daniel daniel hains qui
ressemble un petit peu pardon à une
histoire vraie mais c'est un c'est un
livre alors là franchement il ya des
choses assez et des descriptions de
pubis féminins
tout à fait une excitante et précise et
puis des dialogues qui moi m'ont fait
penser à philippe rohff donc c'est un je
pense que c'est un écrivain
effectivement the last kiss
ccc il ya beaucoup d'humour beaucoup de
philosophie là il ya quand même bien
dans le roman une héroïne qui était
actrice qui s'appelle daniel qui tourne
loin d'eux et qu'ils dont il soupçonne
qu'elle le trompe bien sûr d'où le
changement de titre qui est un clin
d'oeil à mon avis par rapport à la file
d'invités exactement c'est ça ben merci
oui c'est le seul le ternen problème
est-ce que nous sommes assez intéressant
dans une biographie dans ma vie sauf la
vôtre madame tour nous mettre devant
et dire voilà regardez moi je suis
absolument sublime et il faut m'écoute
et me lire je vais vous raconter mon
truc je ne pense pas tout à fait ça je
pense que que la différence entre la
l'autobiographie et le roman est quand
même très nette et quand je dis
autrement c'est que il faut repenser le
loto quoi il faut il faut en faire des
choses dans ces tasses et enfin moi j'ai
vu votre autobiographie je suis désolé
c'est à dire que elle tourne loi de lui
lui la soupçonne de le tromper les gens
qui l'entourent vous appelez ça les gens
de mer de la cour de l'actrice en
question vous appelez ça les gens de
merde à moi c'est à hollywood on appelle
ça les chefs du pipeau ouais la
traduction exacte un genre de merde
oui mais
non est ce que vous êtes en train de
s'expliquer l'accès à un roman qui n'est
pas autobiographique j'essaie de vous
dire que c'est un autre roman c'est à
dire que l'appartement est aussi
importante que la par auto alors ceux
qui s'amusent véritablement à suivre le
voici et le gala et le machin ils
verront sans doute loto mais ceux qui
aiment la littérature je retrouve mon
d'accord voilà verront l'homme était
dans la catégorie électeurs de wet seal
a d'un coup on peut dire que ça vaut
c'est pas moi je vois cette actrice qui
tourne
louisienne fiancés se fit morceau qui
qui tourne loin lui bois alors
effectivement cette boisson créé des
perturbations dans sa vie érotique elle
par hollywood il l'a rejoint le rêve en
anglais alors moi je suis très content
effectivement en tant que lecteur vous
aviez pas crédible merci
non si elle a fait j'aime ce qui est
vraiment très loin d'être con alors
donnez moi la grâce d'être moins con
d'accord toutes façons servat j'ai
l'impression que c'est un livre sur la
douleur c'est un livre sur sur un homme
seul mais il n'est pas spécialement
fidèles lui non plus le narrateur
il s'ennuie pas de son côté
ses tresses c'est très sexuel enfin
james bond
il y en a eu trois françaises de daniel
qui ont fait des james bond à elle peut
choisir laquelle s si on veut vraiment
vous avez pas nous expliquer quand même
que c'est parce qu'ils marceau dont il
saisit quand même non je veux vous
expliquer que ma vie privée me regarde
moi mais pour vous faites des bouquins
sur votre vie privée alors à ces
patients avaient pris vers roman
ouais thierry non en fait ce fils a tiré
la première quand on a fait son film
parlez moi d'amour je sais pas je les ai
pas vus loulay pas vu monsieur je vous
le dis assez d'histoires intello
renfermait coléreux un peu alcoolique
monacale
c'est vous un traitement commence à vélo
sa barbe ce que vous savez quel est le
titre de son roman le premier qu'elle a
écrit d'ailleurs le seul bien c'est une
monteuse ça vous dit quelque chose
il a elle préparera porteuse mais
beaucoup de travail de 6 au plus non je
ne voudrais pas je voudrais pas que ça
descende l'impasse que je pense que que
cgg le la velléité de penser que c'est
un vrai bouquin ouais et les vrais
bouquins sont fait de notre trip l'autre
souffrance de ce conseil mais ils ne
sont pas là pour faire des dénonciations
des
d'espèces d'appel personnel je ne
voudrais pas conçu comme ça je serais
très mal hausse et comme ça je crois que
c'est une conversation très intéressante
parce que très littéraire
aragon appelle ça le mentir vrai c'est
exactement ça et parce donc six teintes
c'était intéressant vous ayez cette
conversation d'une certaine manière si
le lecteur et voyeur c'est son problème
c'est pas de l'autre mais il a tous les
droits oui ce qui est tellement informé
par le les journaux le public la
télévision il a il a tous les droits et
en plus on se dérobe pas à ça moi je ne
me dérobe pas
thierry je me dérobe pas à dire qu' une
partie du bouquin parle d'une vérité que
je connais mais je ne dis pas que c'est
l'entière vérité et je ne dis pas
intégralement que c'est le portrait
craché de quelqu'un ou de quelque chose
c'est parce que j'ai aimé dans le
bouquin justement c'est ce que j'aurai
ce que j'aurai vécu à votre place c'est
à dire cette sensation de non non non je
vous en prie vous en prie n'aimait pas
ce que j'ai vécu ah non mais moi je
rends villareal à l'époque janvier mais
j'ai eu envie moi voilà très aisée sur
ses terres et quand le héros sais pas
vous mais on vérifier le calcul en se
disant est ce qu elle a eu le temps de
voir l'autre c'est grave quand vous
parlez de rudolf hren nikki qui enferme
sa femme de 26 ans à cleppé tellement il
est jaloux non je veux pas vivre ça vous
avez raison vous avez raison je veux
plus vous êtes dans un film je sais pas
je sais pas pendant trois ans à l'idée
quand j'entendais le mot signe films
cinéma acteur actrice je venais quand
même un peu vert pâle dont j'avais pas
très envie c'était pas appétissant c'est
une expérience de la vie maintenant ça
s'écarte et puis je pense que les phares
sont revenus
encore une fois embêter beaucoup de
monde avec un film un peu trop ceci ou
un peu trop cela voilà ça revient
je n'ai vu qu'un film devos et
l'important c'est d'aimer trouvé ça
super c'est pas franchement à grand film
merci en tous les cas d'avoir été
remercié
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux